what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so jumping back into the events of
infinity wars to kind of get you guys
caught up for a second is simply what's
going on here is we only really have
like three worlds going on right now
like like from the perspective of this
story we're only dealing with three
universes there's still an infinite
number of universes out there but from
this perspective we're only dealing with
three universes right now the main
Marvel Universe has really just kind of
been annihilated in its entirety then
you have soul world and then you have of
course the quarry of creation and again
like like we've talked about this in the
previous previous videos that with with
soul world it was never so it was never
a whole universe right like soul world
was just like a little pocket dimension
like imagine that you lived in a
universe that was the size of like New
York City and that's basically what soul
world was it was a tiny little localized
space inside of of the soul stone and it
was kept small because so few people
ever wielded it that the the space that
was needed to house them was always very
very small but I thought you means Loki
had basically taken the the Infinity
stones as they existed in the the real
world in the I'm sorry in the main
Marvel Universe and basically stole them
everybody in Soul world but then you've
also got a second set of Infinity stones
that reside within soul world and so
what it basically gone on here is that
with Loki taking these stones and then
leaving for the purpose of trying to
achieve whatever this greater goal
happened to be with us never really
being told what it was as soon as he
gets out into the main Marvel Universe
what we end up finding out is there's
nothing there anymore that all you
really have word is just kind of like
this huge vast empty space and then you
have the Celestials themselves and the
Celestials never talk and that's one of
the things to bear in mind when it comes
to Celestials in Marvel Comics and
that's why when Loki addresses they may
never speak to him and instead one of
them just kind of points over to a
particular direction
Loki goes and looks he looked into a
mirror we don't see what Loki sees as
that's never offered as an explanation
to us he's basically you know it kind of
pulls back the tapestry and he sees what
awaits for him and then he basically
just kind of quits he basically gives up
and says yep that's pretty much it and
it's kind of lackluster in reality it
makes sense if that's something that's
revealed later on down the line but it's
not Loki just pulls back the tapestry
and just says ah yep so this is
basically kind of like a zero sum and
then leaves and it really seems more
like Jiri Duggan's way of just kind of
saying okay we have to wrap this up
somehow and we can't really explore what
goes on with Loki so we'll just kind of
write it off we'll be done and then Loki
will leave and that will be it so he
essentially comes back with the soul
stones from soul world you know because
of course they work within that
localized space and and work within the
quarry of creation and when he brings
them
back there basically given to you what's
left of Adam warlock infinity watch team
and then Loki just kind of jumps on his
boat and then just sails off back to him
to Putin City and that's the end of that
it's kind of weird it really kind of
seems to come out of left field but the
fact remains that that going back to
soul world again you have Devon dray
that's kind of interesting thing there's
one of the interesting things that jury
duty in did he's very much taking a page
at a jim Starlin and what i mean here is
that for years and years for decades
Galactus just had this hunger and more
often than not the hunger of Galactus
was attributed to the fact that he was
born out of a dead universe into a new
one and the role he plays is to main
basically ensure that like the celestial
population doesn't doesn't go unchecked
when they plant their their seeds inside
of a planet so that that planet will
give birth to a new celestial Galactus
goes around and consumes planet so the
Celestials don't just plant their seed
everywhere and then you've got a
universe overrun with Celestials when
jim Starlin came along and wrote the
Thanos miniseries what he established
was that the hunger of Galactus was
actually like an other dimensional
entity now it was a terrible story and
it was a terrible idea but Jerry did is
kind of taken a page out of that by
saying that the reason why the soul
stone hungers for souls is because it
houses the being Devon drew and that had
never really been explained up to this
point it was just the being Devon Dre is
there and we were never really given an
explanation of what of what rolled of
andra plays outside of the fact that it
just consumes everything inside and what
seems to have gone on here is that where
the soul stone came into existence when
the entity nemesis scatters essence
across the universe in the form of the
Infinity stones that when the soul stone
came into existence Devon Durr was born
inside the soul stone and when that
happened to von Drake had a constant
hunger to consume souls the difference
here is that when infinity Wars happen
and Gomorrah basically took all the life
in the main Marvel Universe put it all
inside of of the soul world and then
bent it onto itself to basically start
merging people in order to essentially
conserve space that what this did is a
basically open to von der up to the idea
now there's just like all these
different beings that are out there now
that it can eat so it just kind of went
on like a like a feeding frenzy
consuming like everything it could come
across until it happen to come across
the heroes here and so the result is
that they're basically fighting off
against it as best they can and that's
really kind of just what's going on at
the moment they're just fighting off
against it as best they can and so again
things get wrapped up pretty quickly
because we know in order to kind of deal
with this threat what the Incredible
Hulk does is use the the space stone run
upon Devon dura create a black hole
inside the entity which literally just
like sucks it into this singularity and
that's the end of
it gets wrapped up like that and again
that's this kind of a common theme in
this story is that they just kind of get
wrapped up in like one page and it's
just kind of like okay and so then you
turn around you have Adam warlock who
sits down and says the main Marvel
Universe has basically been wiped out
all you have is the universe inside soul
world and then like they've left the
quarry of creation so all this left
right now is the main model universe
holds it onto itself in Soul world and
so Adam warlocks idea is to basically
restore everything back to normal the
quandary that that Adam warlock has and
what Jerry Dugan kind of toys with here
is what the aftermath will be will it
certainly be a reboot which is what
Marvel should have done out of Secret
Wars or is everything gonna go back to
normal and the reality is that
everything's gonna go back to normal
everything is gonna kind of reset the
way it was the thing that you take away
from this is that the Infinity warps
universe is basically copied right so I
mean imagine it's a piece of paper a
piece of papers just been folded onto
itself like that's what Gamora dish you
took a piece of paper which was the name
of a universe fold it onto itself and
then put it inside sole world and that's
infinity warps that's the universe that
exists in Soul world what Adam warlock
is gonna do is he's gonna copy that
folded piece of paper and then he's
gonna take it out of soul world that
he's gonna unfold it and that's gonna be
the main Marvel Universe going back to
normal and it kind of makes sense in
terms of just fixing everything the
issue that they have here is that
there's basically like they can't leave
infinity warps inside the soul world
forever like they can't leave it there
for all time and so what they end up
doing is creating basically like two
universes and then in turn just sort of
dispersing everything among those two
universes and so it restores infinity
warps and it restores the main Marvel
Universe now what this does going
forward is it lays the groundwork for
Marvel to start exploring infinity warps
which in reality I mean they kind of
tease it a little bit with regards to
the actual infinity war story I didn't
read any of them because none of them
interested me but you know it does leave
the door open for them to start
exploring that or to do whatever they
want with that universe turn it into the
ultimate universe or anything along
those lines they can essentially do
whatever they want here and so once
everything goes back to normal then Adam
warlock kind of has this second the
second struggle which is can we go back
and undo all this like is it possible to
change all this and that's one of the
things he kind of deals with you one of
these to bear in mind and this is one of
the things that jim Starlin discuss and
infinity
I can't which one it was but it was the
one where Thanos enters the mind of Adam
warlock and Adam warlock enters of mind
of Thanos
to see how the other views all of
creation how they meet themselves and
how they be the universe and so on and
one of the things jim Starlin
established in that story is that Adam
warlock is a being of order
and structure if the universe were left
to Adam warlock if he had total power
and he could create the universe in his
own image it would be rigid and
structured there would be no real free
thought there would be no real freedom
of choice or anything like that
there'd be no free will and so Adam
warlocks kind of struggling with that
internally in terms of yes I can I can
make everything the way that I wanted to
be or I can go back in time and stop
this but there's always consequences
remember branch universe theory so if
Adam warlock goes back and he changes
things then what that means is there's a
universe out there where he didn't
change anything and the question that
has to be asked here is which one will
become the main Marvel Universe and so
it's just kind of a risk it's a gamble
for for Adam warlock but at the end of
the day what he does is he makes the
choice he disperses Gamora sins are out
there here's the Infinity stones and
says like I'm basically removing her and
sitting her to a place where she can
quote-unquote do the most good whatever
the heck that happens to me and then in
turn what he does is he gives the
infinity of Jim's Souls right he goes
right back to the point right after they
get there and he gives infinity of Jim's
Souls and he basically says each of
these infinite II stones can now make
their own decisions they can go live
their lives freely and kind of disperse
now Jerry dude is not pulling that out
of thin air right that's one of the
things that was established and Brian
Michael Bendis is Illuminati run on some
degree they have some measure of
sentience because they all want to be
reunited it's one of the reason of the
ways that Bendis explained how it is
people always end up acquiring all the
Infinity stones that if you acquire one
of them it will lead you to all the
others and the more you gather the
easier it will be to locate the others
Adam warlock kind of builds on that and
says now they're sentient beings now
they can go out there forge their own
paths and do their own thing and what it
does is again that sets the stage for
Marvel to start focusing on people
arbitrarily getting the Infinity stones
introducing new characters some
character we've ever seen or heard of
before who suddenly gains an infinity
stone you know the other half of this is
again gomorrah's basically been whisked
off to another location we're not sure
exactly where it is on some far-flung
distant planet where she ends up
uncovering this this really kind of a
tomb slash casket made of rock which
houses the magnets the evil future
alternate personality of Adam warlock
and this is what I want to kind of talk
about for a second when it comes to comp
when it comes to stories that we cover
by and large I usually try not to throw
my opinion in there in the extreme right
like I throw it out to you guys explain
what's going on give you guys some
history on the characters who were there
how it all kind of ties together into
the history of Marvel Comics and then
you guys come to your own conclusions
but in reality I don't know what the
point of this story was except I guess
maybe make money it just kind of didn't
really seem to serve a purpose because
in a nutshell here's what
happens gomorrah gets the Infinity
stones because she believes she could
fix everything
she does this by taking the main Marvel
Universe folding it in half throwing it
into sole world this introduces infinity
warps basically characters from Marvel
Comics superheroes from omec how many
super villains who have emerged into a
singular being which was kind of fun I
guess if that was your thing what's left
of the heroes basically band together
and they start fighting off against you
know what's essentially the hunger of
the soul stone given physical form in
the form of Devon drew Gamora wants to
go to the quarry of creation to recreate
everything only to find out she can't
the heroes are still fighting to von der
for a little while they finally make
their way out Loki's there somehow doing
something but we never find out what it
is because he never does it and then he
leaves and goes home and then this story
ends and that's basically it in a
nutshell it doesn't really seem to have
served a purpose at all and more often
than not here's here's one of the
important things I mean if this is a
story that's a stepping stone to
something much bigger did it wasn't
really felt because in Marvel Comics and
it really had cover books as a whole DC
Comics Marvel Comics the whole nine
yards when stories are stepping stones
to something bigger then it's obvious
when you feel it like you got I can you
look at Chris Claremont x-men it was
nothing but building blocks that's all
it was one builds to two builds to three
builds to fork we got more modern
stories and and you you look at these
events like loki becoming sorcerer
supreme which happened three months ago
in in dr. strange and the stories serve
the purpose of building on top of things
i'm setting the stage for something else
and is tangible and you can feel it when
you're reading the story for this like
everything like this crazy event
happened and now nobody remembers and
it's all basically undone and it's kind
of like okay so like we're right back
where we started and so it's kinda like
what was the point of it all so i don't
know maybe it's maybe one of you guys
got something out of it more than i did
I'm not really sure me I don't mean to
be negative and overly criticized it's
just as a person who's been reading
comics for over twenty years
I see stories like this and they never
usually bode well they never usually
have longevity because they don't lead
to anything it doesn't actually go into
anything instead as a story 5 or 6 arcs
down the line you get basically just say
well we can you could just ignore that
and Burton didn't exist like weird like
it's like spider-verse right like
technically speaking you could pretend
like spider-verse never happened because
it happened between two issues of
superior spider-man like issue 21 and 22
like it's not like there's an aftermath
to spider-verse where I saw like
spider-verse happens and then it has a
ripple effect throughout the rest of
superior spider-man going into all-new
all-different or I guess the return of
Peter Parker and then all-new
all-different amazing spider-man Spidey
verse is never referenced again I don't
know I mean you know even now is with
secret Empire it's still referenced you
know I mean it was just it was
referenced in the superior octopus
one-shot for you know for the smite
getting tie-in so again I don't know I
mean let me know what you guys think
down in the comment section I'm curious
what your take is because again I don't
normally do this but I don't normally
read stories that in this way like
stories don't the stories don't usually
happen like this in Marvel Comics so
it's kind of crazy and again it doesn't
really seem they're sort of purpose at
all so with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here too comments explained make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]